-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers
And this is "Late Night."
We're so happy
you're joining us.
And now let's get to the news.
During a visit to
the White House yesterday,
pop star Olivia Rodrigo
made a surprise appearance
at the afternoon press briefin
to help promote
youth vaccinations,
which should have a big impact
on the millions of teens
who watch the White House
press briefings.
That's right.
Pop star Olivia Rodrigo
made a surprise appearance a
the afternoon press briefings.
It was almost as surprisin
as when Sarah Sanders
would appear at one.
"It's been months!"
According to a new book,
Chairman of the Joint Chiefs
of Staff General Mark Milley
was worried that
former President Trump
would try to incite a coup
after losing the 2020 election
We really need to come up with
a better early-warning syste
than tell-all books.
"We're in danger.
Quick, get me a typewriter!"
Senate Democrats
unveiled details yesterday
for their new $3.5 trillio
spending proposal
focusing on so-called
human infrastructure,
which will include money
for childcare,
paid family leave,
and housing programs,
or, as Republicans
are calling it,
socialism, fascism,
and critical race theory.
Facebook reportedly fired
more than 50 employees
for spying on people,
including men who used
the platform's data
to follow women they were
romantically interested in
Oh, wow, they fired the gu
who created the site
for that exact reason?
Republican Representative
Matt Gaetz
attended a rally
in Los Angeles yesterday
in support of pop star
Britney Spears.
It's the most worked up
he's ever been
about a woman in her 30s.
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis'
campaign this week
unveiled new merchandise,
which includes a drink koozi
that says,
"Don't Fauci my Florida."
It's a great way to
keep your beer cold
while you try to figure ou
what the hell that means.
Microsoft said yesterday
that it may be bringing back
its virtual assistant Clippy
the paperclip as an emoji.
It won't have any of
the functions of the
original Clippy,
so it will be about as helpful
And finally, a hospital in
Cleveland recently apologize
after mistakenly
giving a patient
a kidney
meant for another patient.
And it's worse than you thin
because this
is the other patient.
[ Laughter ]
That was a monologue, everybody.